مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره معي انا عبيده
نفاق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كريستيانو رونالدو طلع بعد مباراه سيلتا
فيغو والنصر السعودي وقال تصريحات قويه
جدا قال لن اذهب الى الدوري الامريكي لانه
الدوري السعودي حاليا اقوى من الدوري
الامريكي اليوم بهاي الحلقه رح نطرح هذا
التساؤل هل فعلا الدوري السعودي افضل من
الدوري الامريكي ولا الامور بعدها لا
لصالح الدوري الامريكي اكثر
بكل صراحه وبادئ ما ندخل بهذا النقاش
خلينا نتفق على نقطه رئيسيه انه الدوله
الامريكي
حاليا بال 1975 لما استقطت بيليه على
نيويوركوزموس وجاد فرانز على نفس الفريق
وعلى مدار عقود الدوري الامريكي حاول ان
يستقطب العديد من اللاعبين مثل كاكا وبيكه
لا بالنهايه وصلنا لجيل ليونيل ميسي
وبوسكيتس والبا مؤخرا
خلال هاي الفتره كانت دور الامريكي عم
يحاول يعمل شغلتين رئيسيتين عم بيحاول
يخلي الدوله الامريكي واحد من افضل دوريات
العالم بحلول عام 2022 وعم يحاول بنفس
الوقت انه يزيد شعبيه كره القدم في امريكا
لانه هي عائد اقتصادي او رافد اقتصادي مهم
جدا بوجود كره السله والبيسبول وكره القدم
الامريكيه كره القدم في امريكا ما فيها
اهتمام كبير مثل ما كنا بنعرف ولكن في
عوائق كبيره واجهت الدوري الامريكي مثل ما
حكينا كان هدفه ب 2022 انه يخلي الدوري
الامريكي واحد من الافضل في العالم ولكن
الحقيقه انه الدور الامريكي لحد الان
يعتبر دوري متقاعدين تطلق عليه هذه
التسميه لانه معظم اللاعبين الكبار اللي
بيروحوا على الدوله الامريكي بروحوا
بنهايه مسيرتهم بيروحوا رايحين يخلصوا
وبالتالي الجماهير مش كثير بتهتم بهؤلاء
اللاعبين انه هذا خلص كره قدم وخلص مع
السلامه
الدوري السعودي انتبه لهذا الموضوع
والتعاقدات اللي عم يعملها هي مش تعاقدات
مع لعيبه كبار كثير بالسن لما نحكي عن 29
سنه او 28 سنه لما نحكي عن جوتا 24 سنه
لما نحكي عن كوليبالي وحده وتلاتين عن مده
32 وبالتالي اعمار اللاعبين مش كثير كبيره
لا بل انه في لاعبين بقمه مستواهم بنزيما
فايز الكره الذهبيه السنه الماضيه عنا
مارسيلو لاعب نهائي دوري ابطال اوروبا
الموسم الماضي وبالتالي انتبهوا لهاي
الجزئيه وما رح يواجهوا فيها التحدي اللي
امريكا عم تواجهوا او واجهته على مدار
السنوات الماضي العامل الثاني اللي عطل
تقدم الدوري الامريكي وتطوره هو عامل
التوقيت توقيت المباريات كان دائما صعب
بالنسبه لبقيه المشجعين حول العالم
لاوروبا
لعديد من القارات كان صعب انك تحضر
مباريات دوري الامريكي لانه في فرق توقيت
كبير بينها وبين بقيه دول العالم هذا امر
ايضا السعوديه ما راح تواجهه والفكره
الاخيره اللي واجهها الدوله الامريكي هو
مثل ما حكينا انه ما في شع لكره القدم في
امريكا وهذا امر ايضا السعودي ما راح
تعاني منه لان السعوديه عندها شعبيه جارفه
لكره القدم وكره القدم هي اللعبه الشعبيه
الاولى والكاسحه في السعوديه طيب على صعيد
الارقام من يتفوق على صعيد القيمه السوقيه
للاعبين في الدوله الامريكي والدوري
السعودي لحد الان الدوري الامريكي يتفوق
بواحد فاصله اربعه مليار دولار امريكي
وفقا لموقع بمقابل تقريبا 517 مليون دولار
للدوري السعودي اما على صعيد قيمه
اللاعبين او من اللاعب الاعلى قيمه بين
الدوريين فاميلين كوفيتش ثابت بالدوري
السعودي هو اغلى لاعب 56 مليون دولار
تقريبا بمقابل ليونيل ميسي بالدوري
الامريكي ب 39 مليون دولار امريكي تقريبا
الارقام بتبين انه الدوري الامريكي اكيد
راح يكون عنده قيمه اكبر للاعبين لانه
الدوله الامريكي مثل ما حكينا نبلش من
سنوات طويله بهذا الامر لا بل انه في
انديه بالدوري الامريكي وصلت قيمتها
السوقيه بالماركت مليار دولار وهو نادي
طبعا
قريب جدا من هذا الرقم عنده 999 تقريبا
مليون او 900 يعني بحدود التسعينات نسيان
الرقم بالضبط ولكنه قريب ايضا من يوصل
مليار في عنا تقريبا سبعه انديه امريكيه
بين الانديه الاغلى في العالم او بين 30
نادي الاغلى في العالم وهذا امر ببين ايضا
انه على صعيد الاقتصاد او على الصعيد
الاقتصادي بلشت تجربه الامريكيه تؤتي
ثمارها وبلش يبين او بلشت تبين ثمار
النجاح الدوري السعودي الان بعده عم يبلش
وبالتالي محتاج شويه وقت ليوصل لهاي
المرحله هدف السعوديه هي رفع قيمه الدوري
السعودي عامه
لا يوصل لحوالي 8 مليارات ريال تقريبا
ورفع الايرادات ايضا وبالتالي هاي عوامل
كلياتها بتيجي مع الوقت ومع التعاقد مع
اللاعبين ومع زياده الزخم على الدوري
السعودي الدوري الامريكي الان اعتقد انه
بلش يتفوق بموضوع اخر ايضا هذا ممكن يلعب
دور كبير بزياده الاهتمام بالدوري
الامريكي وهو التعاقد مع ليونيل ميسي يقال
او في تقارير صحفيه نقلت تصريحات اللي هو
احد ملاك نادي انتر ميامي اللي انتقل عليه
ليونيل ميسي عم يقول في انه مشاهدات تقديم
ليونيل ميسي وصلت لتقريبا حوالي 3.5 مليار
بني ادم حول العالم وهذا رقم مهول جدا حتى
لو كان مبالغ فيه فبالتاكيد انه الانظار
راح تتجه للدوله الامريكي الموسم المقبل
لمشاهده ليونيل ميسي مش عارفين الحجم ولكن
بالتاكيد راح يكون في اهتمام كبير بسبب
وجود لينا المسيه بالدوري الامريكي طبعا
انتر ميامي راح يستفيد كثير من عوامل بيع
القمصان وشفنا النصر كيف استفاد من
رونالدو على هذا الصعيد بكل الاحوال
المقارنه بين الدوريات الامريكي والسعودي
صعبه جدا على صعيد الارقام لانه بالنهايه
في دوري نبلش من زمان ودوره تبلش حديثا
ولكن قياسا للتطور خلال فتره زمنيه اكيد
الدوري السعودي يتفوق لانه عم يتطور بشكل
كبير وقد يصدم العالم بارقام قياسيه قريبا
جدا هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافيه
حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل كونوا بالف خير